The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, well, Mark
Jarzombek is a professor of
architecture here and has
written this really
interesting book.
MARK JARZOMBEK: So if you have
any questions about something
you don't understand, or you
need to clarify or elaborate,
just raise your hand
and say so.
I just sort of picked
some images out.
First, I'm sure you've seen
the Rogers Building, which
doesn't exist anymore,
as you know.
I mean, this building
still exists.
I'm not sure what happened
to the store.
Did they go bankrupt?
[INAUDIBLE].
But this was torn down.
But what I point out in my book
is that if we look at
this and we go, well, it's
1860s, and you want to make a
building for an institute that
does sciences, what do you do?
I mean, what should
it look like?
And so we may look at this and
say, well, it's sort of a
building like any
other building.
But it's sort of a bit of a
problem because that type of a
building didn't really exist.
So the architect did something
that was pretty clever, but
also says something about
the world view.
Basically the building is
modeled a little bit on the
Apsley House.
And basically is a gentleman's
residence.
So you want to make
a building.
You want to make scientist and
technology guys, miners
walking around in their big
boots, you want to tell them
that they're basically not just
doing technology, but
basically they're gentlemen.
So the students that are coming
in here are meant to be
raised at a level of gentlemen
in the 19th
century sense of that.
They're sort of cultural
holders of a
type of cultural thing.
They're not just wandering
around, shuffling around with
slide rulers in their hand
thinking about science.
They have a certain
status in society.
So basically this is a
gentleman's residence that is,
then, sort of designed on the
inside to be a school.
So this says something about the
transition of science into
legitimacy.
And the type of premodern notion
signs, where science
was still associated with sort
of a gentlemanly class and
gentlemanly behavior.
So that is MIT's first
source of claim,
which was very expected.
Perhaps you think of the
mid-19th century worldview.
Of course, what happens is that
MIT grows gangbusters and
starts to spread out
in every direction.
So there you see the
Rogers Building.
And then there's their Walker
building, which is a chemistry
building, a beautiful
building.
One of the first buildings
specifically designed for
chemical fumes and so forth.
And then here and there and
right and left, the campus
expands around Copley Square
into warehouses and into sheds
and other things.
The Lowell Laboratory
gets built here.
But as you can see, after
a while, it's
something like 20 buildings.
The face was that not only is
the buildings all over around
Copley Square--
which is difficult if you want
to go from class to class in
the middle of a snowstorm--
but also, science was
changing, too.
So the professors were
complaining they needed dust
free environments to
do certain things.
They needed laboratories that
won't shake every time the
beer truck rumbles by.
So if you're in the middle of
a city, 19th century cities
where unbelievably stinky, fumy
places filled with black
soot from chimneys.
I mean, today clean air law has
done a lot to our cities.
But you've got to imagine, into
the winter the heavy odor
and cloud of soot making
everything sort of black.
And so if you do any experiments
that require
special atmospheres,
and this and that.
So the professors were
complaining about
being in the city.
They wanted to be away from the
city, away from the noise,
and the pollution, and
the sounds, and all
that type of stuff.
So this was sort of one
of the problems
that the faculty faced.
And one of the reasons
that spread along
the desire to move.
So then the question was,
well, what you do?
So you need a bigger building.
So the model for this was
actually in Europe, mainly in
Germany, and then Switzerland.
So the ETH was created, you see,
almost at the same time,
but designed a little
bit earlier.
Gigantic building.
So here, I mean, this makes MIT
look, I mean, literally,
like a joke compared to what
the Swiss investment in
technology was at that time.
Huge building, massive amount of
laboratories, huge library.
I mean, this was an institution
of gigantic scale.
So here we have the United
States trying to create some
enthusiasm for the independence
of science and
learning and technology as
a material, and basically
adopting, initially at least,
not the German model, which
was that this is a massive
institution supported by the
state government.
And it still is.
The ETH is financed and
supported by the state
government.
If you're a professor there,
the prime minister has to,
ultimately, accept your
tenure proposal, not
the university president.
Whereas MIT adopted sort of the
English gentleman model.
Which is very low key,
different worldview.
Ultimately, of course,
this wins out.
But the transition
is what's sort of
interesting about this.
So Robert Ware, who's founded
the School of
Architecture here.
"The first principle of
architecture is truthfulness,
good sense, perspicuity.
Considerations of method,
order, form, clearness,
precision, sobriety, are what
make a good working style,
both in writing and in
building." So in other words,
he's describing a building.
But in reality, he's also
describing what it means to be
a gentleman.
A gentleman is truthful,
and good, and has great
perspicuity.
Order, form, clearness,
precision, sobriety--
this is what you tell
a young man to be.
So in some sense, we can sort
of read through some of the
architectural mandate a type of
relationship to, in fact,
MIT's mandate, which was
what kind of men--
because it was all men in those
days-- what kind of man
are we trying to shape here?
But then, of course,
the world changed.
So in 1863, we have the four
categories, of which basically
fine arts and architecture
is the only one
that survives as such.
Course four is the only one that
sort of keeps us going.
But you see in 1873 all
of a sudden we have
different type of world.
It's astonishing how in
basically 10 years, MIT's
mindset has changed.
So before, we had agriculture.
Farmer Joe wanted to figure
out how to lay
out a field, right?
Well, agriculture, we don't
do agriculture anymore.
I mean, go out in
Kansas for that.
At the top of the heap is
civil engineering now.
So you can sort of see, you go
from an institution that is
really sort of about
agriculture, geology,
chemistry, very sort
of oddly primitive.
I don't know, you know?
It's sort of an institution
where we could sort of see
modernity being formed.
So civil engineering, mechanical
engineering,
geology, architecture
stays, chemistry.
So here, history, geology, and
chemistry were all one
department.
Maybe it's sort of a little
bit hard to imagine that.
You know, natural history,
geology, and chemistry all
being sort of one thing.
But we sort of imagine that
during this time, there was
still debate about, let's
say, for example,
what do you call these?
Dinosaur bones in the sand.
What do you call them?
Fossils.
AUDIENCE: Fossils.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Right, right.
You don't know, OK.
So up until 1820, 1830, they
all said that God put the
fossils there because they were
the mistakes that when he
made heaven and earth, he
made a few mistakes.
So he put them in the ground
so no one would see them.
And this was a current theory.
And people thought this
was sort of it.
So geology was sort of having to
do with divinity, in a way.
Because when you started
digging, you encounter fossil.
It's like, there's
God's mistake.
And it's like, what
do you do with it?
I mean, he should cover it up.
So geology, chemistry,
everything, these ideas were
still floating around.
I mean, not so much here.
But you can sort of see geology
wasn't what this is.
And you can see where
geology is going.
It goes from just looking
at stones to mining.
Which we can sort of see by the
time we get to 1900 a much
more sort of precise focus of
how the sciences sort of
operate in the real world now.
Here this is sort of
all very abstract.
Here we see the emergence of
whole new genres of reality.
We have a philosophy
department.
Philosophy disappears and then,
in a funny way, sort of
comes back in the
20th century.
So philosophy is still the
holdover of the idea that you
should know something
about the world in a
philosophical way.
So by 1873, we see the
emergence of the
professionalization of the
sciences, which means
professional journals,
publications.
And think, all the things we
assume completely normal today
just really didn't exist,
actually, until really into
the 1880s and 1890s, sort of
journal publications and peer
reviewed publications, and
so forth like that.
So then by 1900, we see we
have now 13 departments.
So it's sort of growing
exponentially.
And it has continued to grow.
We got, I don't know,
23 AB now.
I mean, we're at least
in the mid '20s.
And we see new things.
America's just had the
Spanish American War.
Naval ships for the Defense
Department are important.
So we have a Naval architecture
thing.
The cities in the turn of the
century were really terrible,
complicated, messy places.
The streets were not paved.
There were sewage problems,
and so forth, and so on.
So sanitary engineering comes
into play along with sort of
the conventional type thing.
So we have new departments and
new programs being developed.
But the point is, in some sense,
what we get here is
really the modern notion of
science that we just assume is
completely normal.
We see it literally happening,
if you will, decade by decade,
rapidly changing into the
professional world that we
have today.
So the model of a gentleman's
villa, it is
just clearly not working.
But of course, the building
remained to be functional for
a long time.
So the first attempt to, in some
sense, modernize MIT's
look was the Walker building.
Here's the Rogers Building
next to it.
And at first you go, well,
it doesn't look
all that much different.
But it was designed with
these chimneys.
You see the air vent chimneys on
the exterior facade so that
the chemistry laboratories would
have these vents going
up to vent the fumes.
So instead of hiding the
chimneys, the chimneys become,
in fact, part of the
whole architecture.
And basically it's sort of the
first real attempt to make a
laboratory building at
a monumental scale.
This is in Copley Square,
right across
from Trinity Church.
This is one of the best real
state areas in the city.
And to put a chemistry lab
there, I mean, it's like, oh,
you got to be kidding
me, right?
So it shows the capacity to sort
of start to think of what
a science building is
at an urban scale.
But still, it's a relatively
small building.
They were living in these
type of warehouses.
This was the architecture
building
and engineering building.
Which were useful, because you
could much around in there.
And there was no damage
done, really, if you
banged in to something.
They made some of these
experiments.
They made the lower laboratory
down here, which at the time
would have been the most
advanced laboratory for
electrical engineering.
They only used it
for a few years.
The building contractor was
a guy called Gilbreth.
Everybody seen Cheaper
By The Dozen?
Well, anyway, he's the one who
built the building using new
techniques.
Because he was famous.
You know what he
was famous for?
The guy, Gilbreth?
Well, he was interested in
making labor less expensive.
So the ways you do that is you
study, let's say, you take a
bricklayer.
And the bricklayer's got
to go get a brick.
And then he's got to bring
the brick down.
And then he's got to
put a brick in.
Then he's hungry.
They he puts the chewing
gum in his mouth.
And he slathers something
[INAUDIBLE].
Well, he figured out that
takes a lot of time.
So you have the dolly.
And the dolly will
bring the brick.
One guy gives the brick.
The other guy puts it down.
The other guy slathers it.
So your job is just to take
the brick and put it down.
Take the brick, put it down.
Take the brick.
And the next guy's job is to
go-- kuh-chunk, kuh-chunk,
kuh-chunk, kuh-chunk, kuh-chunk,
kuh-chunk.
And you can build buildings a
lot faster if you do this
time-saving thing.
He was the inventor--
or not the inventor but one
of the great champions of
time-saving labor.
Ford Motor works would put it
into mass production window to
make a Model T Ford.
So this was sort of advanced
technology at the
time, if you will.
And of course, has debatable
effects.
But anyway.
So anyway, there he is, Mr.
Gilbreth, with his cheaper by
the dozen family.
And so they hired him.
In other words, they brought in
a new type of engineer to
experiment with a new
type of building.
And so it shows MIT's
search for the
avant-garde of the time.
So then you compare,
of course, that
there's MIT's building.
And this is another building
from 1861.
The Opera by Charles
Garnier in Paris.
I don't know if you've
ever seen it.
But if you go to Paris,
you should see it.
It's certainly one of the great
buildings of the 19th century.
I mean, [? vastly, ?] hugely
beautiful, extravagant building.
So once again, in Europe,
they were making
these gigantic things.
Whereas at MIT and Boston, there
were still small little
building after small
little building.
But they this world, which
is sort of the Beaux-Arts
architecture here is sort of a
European development of how to
make these buildings work within
the city, and so forth.
Wasn't really in the
United States yet.
And I'd say its building styles
were still English
driven, still relatively small
scale, still relatively modest
in their desire in terms
of spacial expression.
So around the world, you were
having these huge buildings
being built.
And so here we are in Japan.
Here's Cairo.
I have to show you this because
this is the old
building from the
medieval period.
And then they built this
gigantic mosque here in 1910.
And the Cairo National Museum of
1900, which is in the news
a little bit today.
So Boston around 1900 would
have looked like a real
gritty, brick, working
class place.
Very few prestigious buildings,
nothing really
grand about the place at all.
You had the Back Bay that
had been laid out.
And you had some fine
residential quarters.
But you really didn't have
high architecture, any
examples of high architecture
at all compared to almost
everywhere else around
the world.
Well, in 1893, they brought in
this French architect, a guy
called Despradelle, to teach in
the school of architecture.
And he sort of changed
everything because he brought
this much grander, much more
imposing sort of tradition of
sort of architectural
world that was in
Europe at the time.
And it was sort of a risk.
And so they bought this guy.
As you can see, he's sort
of a strange character.
The students sort
of loved him.
He was very quirky much beloved
by the students.
We taught them how to make these
absolutely drop dead
gorgeous drawings, some of
which are in the museum.
Hopefully we can, one
day, exhibit them.
This drawing, which was
gigantic, some 12 feet high or
something, was for a building,
of course,
that was never built.
I mean, it was impossible
to build at the time.
Some huge, huge, huge, huge
monument sort of celebrating
the Americas called the
"Beacon of Progress."
So actually it looks a little
old fashioned, because it was,
like, not a modern building.
But it would have been
a really very
early use of concrete.
It was actually a very
interesting type of edifice.
And so we have to see it as much
more progressive than we
today might see things.
And then he went around and
bought drawings for the
students to learn.
So this is another one of the
leading architects of the
time, a guy called
Viollet-le-Duc.
And he and Ware basically
brought all these drawings
from Europe for the architects
to look at to teach them.
So we have, of course, in the
process, then, drawing
capitals and things like that
for presentation drawing.
So all of a sudden, the
principle of architecture,
prestige, quality buildings
sort of comes into play.
And these are just drawings
from the archives made by
students here at the turn
of the century.
So the point is that basically
he changes the architectural
culture that's taught here
from just basically more
pragmatic architectural
buildings to be a type of
culture that really speaks
to high-end architectural
production.
And MIT is really the
first place in the
country which does that.
Now that means you and I will
look at this, and [INAUDIBLE]
all sort of old fashioned.
We look at this and go, oh,
this is the stuff that
modernism sort of got rid of.
But this would be a
bit of a mistake--
this is a synagogue
that was planned--
largely because 1900 and that
era was an interesting moment
in history.
There was the Spanish
American War.
And the two sort of, I
guess, events was the
market crash of 1893.
1893 was the first stock market
crash in the United
States, the first great one.
It's like we never learn.
It was another big bank
financial scandal of too many
people buying too much land.
And then all of a sudden,
it went belly up.
It was like, duh.
So anyway, and basically
everybody was out of a job.
I mean, probably about 10 times
worse than what we have
today, what we just recently
experienced.
And probably not quite as
bad as the crash of '29.
But a significant shock
to the system.
And after that, the United
States' warehouses were filled
with stuff that no
one could buy.
So what they did was they
made it very cheap.
And they shipped it
around the world.
And basically the United States,
afterward from 1893,
basically became an
international supplier of
things, in particular steel.
So it discovered international
markets after 1893.
Then came the Spanish American
War, where America now was a
quasi-colonial imperial power.
So by 1900, the United States
had established itself as a
network, global, expanding
trade world.
And it wanted to market itself
in particular ways.
Well, what you could market,
of course, is architecture.
So MIT knows by teaching its
students how to make these big
and huge and grand buildings,
whilst preparing them for big
time commissions around
the world.
And it's not just these
commissions.
But it was the steel that came
from the steel factories.
It was the parts that
came from the
American parts factories.
It was the labor and the
contractors that came from the
labor contractor.
So this was all originally
controlled by the French,
largely, who built their
buildings as export
commodities.
Now MIT's Department of
Architecture really was sort
of at the cusp of basically
producing architecture as an
export commodity.
So it's not just that this
Beaux-Arts architecture, as we
call it today, is sort
of frilly and cute.
It basically was the first
world export commodity.
Because to make a building,
you need steel, you need
foundations, you need
technology, you need engineers.
At the end, it might look
sort of interesting.
But it's the whole package.
So this is why MIT
developed this.
And meanwhile, Harvard
was looking at this.
And they said, well, if MIT is
gambling for the Beaux-Arts
and the principle of world
domination, we think that this
is sort of not correct.
And we want architecture to be
humble and appropriate to the
human scale.
And so they went into
sort of the
anti-internationalist phase.
They went into what's called
the arts and crafts.
So whereas MIT went into sort
of internationalism,
Beaux-Arts, huge buildings,
Harvard brought in faculty
that made little
Gothic things.
Very beautiful, very sweet,
very elegant.
William Brigham was one of
the professors there.
And these are the things
that he made.
And you compare that with Allen
Ross, who is a graduate
from here, who went
out and built huge
buildings like this.
Or Hood, a graduate from MIT
who went off and did the
Chicago Tribune.
He did other buildings, the
Rockefeller Center, designed
part of the Rockefeller Center,
which were gigantic
buildings, all about
the progressive
spirit and so forth.
So this was the two approaches
that MIT and Harvard had at
the time in architecture.
MIT went for big-scale,
urban, huge projects.
Harvard went for the little
scale, for the domestic, for
the house, and so forth.
Eventually MIT would
win that argument.
I mean, it is a short term or
long term perspective on that.
And Harvard would eventually
bring in a French architect in
the first decades of
the 20th century.
And that was sort of the end
of the arts and crafts.
And so one of the characters
that sort of comes in is, of
course, Bosworth, who
is a product of MIT.
So he, in some sense, is a
student of Despradelle.
He knows and understands
Despradelle's principle of
buildings that represent the
big international scale.
Not buildings that are going to
be humble, and sweet, and
Gothic, and nostalgic.
So the project that he designs
for MIT is at that large,
international scale.
It's meant to be
big and grand.
Now he worked for
various people.
But including a man called
Fish-- who was an AT&T CEO--
and Ware, and some other people,
and Rockefellers.
He was sort of like a
gentleman's architect.
He didn't have a big practice.
He had a small practice.
But basically these super rich
people would bring him in to
design buildings.
So this is one of the
buildings are
designed in New York.
It's literally right next to,
no longer the World Trade
Center, the towers which you
don't see anymore, which would
be right there.
So if any of you know New York,
the Wall Street area,
you would hopefully know
this building.
Really a gorgeous building,
strictly neoclassical.
It has a Doric on the inside,
ionic on the outside.
But it's a steel building.
Basically it's a modern steel
building wrapped in
this sort of casing.
And the casing is meant to show
the stability of AT&T,
the magnificence
of it as well.
So these buildings, which we
may look at as sort of a
little bit old fashioned were,
at that time, all about the
bravura of these new
corporations that were emerging.
So in particular,
sort of AT&T--
AUDIENCE: Is that the West
Street building?
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's where
Bell Labs is
founded, in that building.
Bell Labs is founded
in that building.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah,
that's right.
Bell Labs is founded here.
That's right.
So when MIT, then, was making
the move, they didn't talk to
Bosworth initially.
It came a little bit later.
There's this huge institution.
They're having these problems.
And they were going, well, we
need to find somebody to make
the design.
So they hire this guy
called Childs.
Childs was an expert in
sanitation engineering.
He made the sewer lines
for Brookline.
I mean, OK, he's an
OK architect.
But I mean, the guy
makes sewer lines,
for crying out loud.
So he made a project.
And at first, it looks OK.
He's got a thing.
It's got an esplanade.
It's got its funny towers,
and so forth like that.
But fortunately, they realized
it's really bad.
I mean, it's really, really,
really, really bad.
So his idea was that
X marks the spot.
I mean, literally.
And that this line, if you
look at it, points to the
State House.
Because the State House was
where the money comes from.
So you want an avenue that when
I can look down, I can
see the State House
and say, thank you
very much, State House.
Even though State House was
giving it practically nothing.
They were practically
bankrupt.
So I don't know where these
lines would be pointing to.
But they're just off into
distance somewhere.
And then, as you see, it's
not really symmetrical.
One has got longer.
And then you see there's
a track.
And you see here one building
bumps on the track.
It's really sort of weird,
a weird building, right?
So not a good architect.
And obviously somebody
complained about it.
Well, the guy who complained
about it was this man called
Freeman who was a civil engineer
who would later go
off and design the canals
for Panama Canal.
So this was a really
top civil engineer.
And compared to, if you will,
some local hokey-bonky
architect that they
found in some sort
of neighboring village.
So Freeman comes on the plane
and says, we've got to get rid
of all these architects.
They don't know what they're
talking about.
And convinces the president,
Maclaurin, to fund him to do
some research on what
MIT needs to do.
So he travels around
the world.
He goes to Mexico.
He goes to the United States.
He goes to Canada.
He goes to Germany, and
France, and Italy.
And he collects this portfolio
of plans and photographs.
And then produces his report
that I publish at
the end in my book.
And he falls in love with the
German model of buildings,
like the ones that
I had showed you.
And he said that the Germans
and the Swiss had come up
already 50 years earlier
with this
notion of a giant building.
Not one building in sort
of the landscape in the
gentlemanly fashion.
But huge, mega structures that
if you go to Berlin, and you
go to the Technical University
in Berlin, or these
universities in Zurich.
And so he puts the map
of them together.
And he says, this is
what MIT should do.
I mean, this is what we need.
We need a mega structure,
not just a little
old building somewhere.
And then to make his point, he
makes a design which he says,
OK, this is what a bad
architect would do.
We'll have the architecture
department.
We have a chemistry
We have a physics department.
We've got an electrical
department.
We got some labs.
We'll just scatter them around,
whatever, willy-nilly,
and call that a campus.
And so he makes this sort of
fake plan, if you will, to
show this is how we would do it
if we wanted to be a little
bit like Harvard.
And we might have a quad
in there, and so forth.
He hated architects.
He thought architects were
pompous arrowheads.
He calls them beauty makers.
And basically the
world should be
designed by civil engineers.
And this was sort of an
interesting moment where MIT
Civil Engineering Department is
sort of asserting itself in
the architectural world against
the Beaux-Arts.
So he doesn't like the
Beaux-Arts at all.
He doesn't understand, really.
Because basically by the 1910s,
and so forth, what is
being exported is precisely
dams, and bridges, and canals,
and so forth, not buildings.
So this is where huge
investments of exportation of
MIT's position in the world
has to do with civil
engineering.
And architecture's now a
little bit sort of on a
smaller scale.
So his plan for MIT looks
actually quite like what MIT
looks like.
Basically it's a concrete
building.
Concrete, because
it won't burn.
And today we go, concrete?
The hell with concrete.
But you've got to remember,
the Romans had concrete.
And then sometime in the Middle
Ages because they
didn't believe in science, they
forgot how to make concrete.
And then no one knew
what concrete was.
I mean, it had been completely
forgotten,
basically, until the 1880s.
And people were going, God, we
could make concrete now.
So they started making
concrete.
And people were very
uncertain about it.
Because they needed to test it,
and stretch it, and all
these things.
And then in the early 20th
century, they finally figured
out that by putting steel mesh
into the concrete, you can
sort of give it a substance.
And it can both be compressed
and, in
some sense, also intention.
So that made concrete into
a basically usable thing.
But it was still seen as
sort of a low material.
If you do a public building,
it had to be brick.
Brick was seen as
prestigious--
stone, marble.
The last thing you want
to do is concrete.
The advantage of concrete, of
course, is that it's really
good against fires.
And the building doesn't
shake when the
trucks go rumbling by.
So he designed for this building
to be in concrete.
And it would have been, and in
fact, when it was built, the
largest concrete building in the
world, some million square
feet, sort of giant structure.
And that in itself is, in some
senses, another aspect of MIT
reaching out to a type of really
being the most modern
thing available.
So this is another building
designed as a shoe olfactory.
And you can sort of see it has
the same sort of principle, a
concrete structure with these
columns going down the middle
that become the corridor.
And then all you have to do is
makes slabs, and then the
circulation system for people
to go up and down.
So basically the concrete
columns,
circulations in the corners.
Here is an auditorium.
And then behind here was various
laboratories for the
electrical engineers
and whatnot.
So he did that.
And MIT thought that was
all pretty good.
But they got a little nervous
because they still wanted the
architects to come and give a
blessing to the building.
They had this being built.
Unfortunately, the skin of it
would have still had some
classical furnishings.
Oh, he wanted the skin.
The skin was going to be out of
ceramic, white ceramic, so
that you could wash it down.
You got to remember, in the
winter all the soot makes all
the buildings black.
So he didn't like that.
So he invented this sort of
ceramic that you could just
hose down and the building would
be very gleaming in the
spring again.
So all very clever, very
practical, very useful.
But MIT was a little nervous.
So they went to, as
many institutions
do, the power elite.
So at some moment, President
Maclaurin called up
Rockefeller and said, hey,
Rocky, we're building a
building here.
And can you recommend
something?
So Rockefeller, and this
is Theodore Vail.
Theodore Vail's the President of
AT&T. And you see, he's on
the telephone.
And he's in his little
bungalow in
Jekyll Point in Carolinas.
They had a little
villa out there.
And this is the first
transatlantic telephone call
from his little bungalow in
Jekyll Island-- and that's
where all the rich
people lived--
to California.
So this is the moment where
he's calling this guy and
talking to him in California.
And so he's sitting next
to his buddy, another
millionaire, Rockefeller.
And who are the people
behind him?
Well, they're his architects.
So here he is at this
unbelievably amazing moment.
And it could be his daughter.
It could be his wife.
It could be some engineers.
But he wants to sort of
memorialize this moment by the
two guys being on
the telephone.
And the architects are behind
them who are going to get the
commissions to build the
buildings that will represent
them in the world.
So we saw the one that Bosworth
has just done.
You see him beautifully
attired.
He knows how to dress
in those days.
He's an MIT gentleman.
And so basically we don't
know exactly all
of the ins and outs.
But more or less, Maclaurin
basically calls up
both of these men.
And they both say Bosworth
is the man to do it.
So there was no competition.
There was no announcement
in the paper
looking for an architect.
There was no first they just
went down the street and found
the first shingle where the guy
said, I'm an architect.
Here they called up the top CEOs
and said, we need a guy
who can do this building
that you trust.
Because we don't need simply
someone who can make the
building in a pragmatic way.
We need someone who can give
us the representational
capacity that architects
can bring.
So they pointed to Bosworth.
Now Bosworth used
Freeman's plans.
Basically built Freeman's
building.
Here it is, you can see.
And had this been built more or
less like it was, and glass
put in, it would have been the
first, the largest, and the
most important modern building
in the history of ever.
So 1913, it was just when
modernism was starting to be
discussed in Europe as well.
But the Europeans would
eventually figure out they're
just putting glass.
Let's get rid of all the skin.
Americans were a little bit
more reluctant to do that.
And so that's why the modernism
began in Europe.
But this is basically a modern
building and would have been
in every history book had
they just stopped there.
But they didn't.
And they put the skin on it.
But you can get a sense of
basically the sort of radical,
modern, clean, functional
aesthetic that comes from
Freeman in some of the buildings
and some of the
rooms that are on the corner.
This is an old room now.
It's got a sunk ceiling.
I mean, we do all this
stuff to it.
And you get a very cushy,
different world today.
But you get a little bit of a
sense of Vail, who wanted to
donate his library to MIT.
And he wanted, of course,
Bosworth to design the dome to
house this library.
So this is the Vail Library.
And we see it as it was
originally was.
Now today, it'd look like a
parking garage with these
stupid lamps.
And of course, I mean, I just
go in there, I just really
want to vomit.
It's just really, really,
really bad.
And then in 1941, they
painted the dome.
So they thought the German
airplane bombers were going to
come and bomb MIT.
So they painted the dome so that
you could turn the lights
off and there wouldn't
be any lights.
Of course, the German bombers
never made it to MIT.
And everyone forgot to
take off the paint.
So you go in there and
it's sort of dark.
And you don't have the oculus,
you know, with this warmth of
the light coming down.
And of course, these wonderful
chairs and people
just reading there.
Instead you've got these sort of
bean bags and kids sleeping
and snoring right and left.
So hopefully that can be done
something about that.
So Bosworth took the modern
building, basically, and
wrapped, as you can sort
of see, in a restrained
classical, not the glorious,
usually excessive classicism
that you might find
other places.
But a relatively restrained
classicism.
Very simple sandstone facade.
And of course, the
front of it.
Of course, the whole thing was
paved, because this was, in
some sense, the urban center
of the building.
In the '20s and '30s, paving
is hard to do.
You've got to maintain it.
And if you don't maintain it,
things and weeds grow.
And then the paving does
this and this.
And finally, you just rip the
whole crap out and put in a
few plants.
So that's what they did.
And made it into a park so
that you can't see the
building at all.
But the building was meant to
be sort of really, really
visible, this white, beautiful
structure, visible
from across the river.
Clearly a statement of
constitutionality in the landscape.
And then it was opened in a
big celebration where Vail
gave all the MIT alumni in the
various clubs around the
country headsets.
I think this is in Kansas.
And so they're all listening to
the speech that was taking
place during the opening
ceremony, you
know, all at the same.
So it was the first sort
of simulcast--
I don't know, that wouldn't
be the right phrase--
simultaneous transmission
of sound in the
history of the world.
And to make sure that people
understood, there was a
relationship between AT&T and
his donor, Vail, and MIT.
So this is the front of
the AT&T headquarters.
And here you can see
the doors of them.
And here you see the doors of
MIT, which are basically the
same doors.
So when you walk into the
doors, you're basically
walking into the doors that
say, thank you, Mr.
Vail for your gift.
I mean, it's a bad photograph.
Just take my word for it.
It's the same doors.
It says so even on the
construction drawings, copied
the drawings from the
AT&T headquarters.
So MIT's relationship with
AT&T, with electrical
engineering, with this
progressive corporate world is
sort of cemented in
the building.
So the building we could say
looks like classical.
But in reality, what it's doing
is giving MIT what it
really wanted, which was a type
of relationship to the
corporate America.
Corporate America we
assume has been
around for 8,000 years.
It really hasn't.
It really starts to emerge,
these giant corporations,
exactly at this moment.
So at that level, this building
does what was
happening in corporate
America, too.
These large, impressive,
institutional buildings in the
landscape that are referring to
the classical past as a way
to sort of stabilize the idea
that we're here forever.
Even though we're only a few
years old, don't worry, like
the Doric columns, we'll be
around for a long time.
Good luck.
So of course, this building
refers partially to the dome
of the Pantheon in Rome.
I hope some of you
have seen that.
So we have the dome.
And then we have these sort
of columns in front.
There are eight columns in front
of the real Pantheon.
Whereas there are 10 columns
sort of here.
And of course, the dome
is much, much,
much, much, much, higher.
Because the dome in the
Pantheon is very low.
And actually, you don't
see it all.
You can sort of see it if you're
way up high and you can
sort of photograph it.
But from the street level, you
don't see the dome at all.
So it's not an imitation.
But clearly, obviously he's
saying the dome of the
Pantheon is one of the
great buildings.
Clearly the pantheon translated
into the idea of learning.
And so the Enlightenment project
of the unification of
the sciences.
So that's sort of part of it.
The other part, of course, is
that if you look at the dome
of the Pentagon, you'll notice
these capitals are what you
call Corinthian, which is sort
of a typical type of capital
that was developed in Rome that
does not match up with
here, which is capitals that
are called ionic, which are
actually Greek.
And they're a lot older.
So he's sort of playing with
these languages to craft a
type of MIT message.
So the model that he's
taken is the Temple
of Athena in Priene.
Priene was a Greek town
in Western Turkey.
And so he's using the capitals,
which I show here,
from that temple.
So he wants Athena to be in
there, because Athena's
[? learning. ?]
Among classicists, this temple
is supposed to be seen as the
most perfect temple that
had ever been built.
And if you do architectural
history, you would know that.
So he takes the capital
of Priene here and
basically copies it.
So when you walk in building
seven up on the third floor,
you see these gigantic
capitals.
Well, why spend $2,500 and go
to Turkey and look at it?
Well, you can look at
it right there.
I mean, they're sort
of the same thing.
But as you can see, the
bottoms are different.
Now I know you guys
are like, ugh.
They all had bottoms.
But bottoms--
it's a whole story.
So he's taking the top
but not the bottom.
So where do the bottoms
come from?
Well, the bottoms come from
another temple in Athens
called the Erechtheion.
So here you see MIT's bases.
And compared to the Erechtheion,
they're pretty
much a perfect match.
The Erechtheion, anybody seen
that in Acropolis, Athens?
You guys travel?
You got to travel.
It's a bit of a ruin now.
You don't really get
what it seems.
But it's seen as one of the
most sophisticated of
buildings that the Greeks
had ever produced.
Very complicated building.
Not a classic temple with
a front and a side.
But actually a very, very sort
of complicated temple, showing
that the Greeks could actually
produce temples with porches,
and fronts, and backs,
and this and that.
And such a different
type of complexity.
So it's a building that
shows complexity.
And you can sort of see
these MIT bases.
So he takes the bases from one
temporal to show sort of a
type of architectural mastery
of complexity.
He takes the capitals from
another temple to show Athena,
and knowledge, and sort
of purity of design.
Then he takes the Roman idea of
the great vault which holds
knowledge and the sciences
together and basically makes
that into the message, the
corporate message of MIT that
gets sort of put
into its front.
So today, of course, we look at
buildings and we don't see
them as messages.
We just see them as, wow,
I like that, or
I don't like that.
But this is the great advantage
of what the
classical world brought while
it was still being used, was
that you take the pieces and
you can construct arguments
out of them, depending on how
and what you're referring to.
So this was, in some
sense, a message.
And this was why they brought in
Bosworth to, in some sense,
do Freeman's project.
But basically give it the
proper message that
it needed to have.
And so what you get is really
the best of both worlds, I
think, is this positioning of
MIT in the corporate world, as
the corporate progress of world
was understood at that
time-- right-- in the
emerging world.
But also have in its core--
of the inside--
this sort of fantastic concrete
slab building.
Which was also progressive in
its own right, but it's not
celebrated in any
particular way.
It's just there--
right?
And of course, that interior of
the building got repeatedly
nibbled on and transformed,
and [? resealings ?]
and new windows and doors.
So it's very hard to see that.
The best places are
the staircase.
Which if you just think, 1913,
these really amazingly clear,
functional concrete staircases
that are so simple, you hardly
think that that's anything
to be proud of-- right?
But if you're thinking of what
could have happened-- right?
Which would have been
a building--
free standing buildings
in a quad, like
in the Harvard model.
It would've been a very
different story.
Yeah, that's the end of my
little spiel here about the
old building, at least up
until it was built.
So, questions?
Thoughts?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This is a litle
off-topic, but do you think
the reason why we call Athena
"Athena" has anything to do
with the architecture?
Like, the computer system?
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah,
I don't know.
Could be just coincidence, it
could be just coincidence.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Interesting.
MARK JARZOMBEK: At one moment,
Boston was seen--
was trying to define itself as
the Athens on the Charles.
So the ionic columns that
are on our building--
and if you go to the museum,
the Fine Arts
Museum has ionic columns.
Many of the buildings designed
first by MIT, and then during
the '20s and '30s will
have ionic on them.
Because Boston was sort of
trying to nickname itself as
the Athens of learning and
civilization on the Charles.
So that maybe leaked out.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Was the Infinite
Corridor planned today, like
the [INAUDIBLE]?
MARK JARZOMBEK: Absolutely.
That's right, yeah.
The corridor was--
corridors were complicated
spaces.
We see them today as
pretty generic.
But in those days, corridors
were actually very special
places used--
like a novel types of spaces.
Partly, they were rejected
because they didn't have a
good ventilation.
So you needed to have
very, very tall--
because there's no
air conditioning,
and there's no heating.
So they would be very cold, and
then in summer if you put
bathrooms there, the fumes would
collect and they'd be
sort of stinky, maybe-- right?
So during the 19th century,
you're going to find few
buildings actually designing
with corridors.
But they start emerging in the
late 19th century in state
houses, parliament buildings,
as representational places.
You know when we say someone
is lobbying--
right-- because the corridor was
next to these lobbies in
the parliament building.
So the idea that you could
have these corridors--
places where people
would hang out--
was seen as a positive thing.
But that's one of the reasons
these spaces and the building
was so huge, is because the idea
was the ventilation, you
don't have artificial
ventilation.
So the whole building had to
be circulated through these
windows and through
the corridors.
But yeah, it was designed with
these corridors in mind.
Initially, the idea was that the
offices would have walls
out of very thin wood, and he
called them curtain walls,
which is different from the
technical term today in
architecture.
But they were literally like
curtains, so that if the
physics professor wanted more
space, he could expand or
something like that.
Of course, that turned out to
be completely dysfunctional,
because you give a professor
space, he's never going to
give it up.
I mean, now we have the space
wars at MIT, and it's just
like to death.
We've been trying to move a one
wall between two offices,
now, for 10 years in Department
of Architecture,
and it's just not
gonna happen.
So this idea that this was like
a free plan, where the
corridors are the spine and the
stable part of it, and the
walls are sort of moving and
expanding and contracting as
disciplines.
Because he knew that disciplines
were moving and
contracting.
So he wanted a building that
was very flexible.
That's why there are no walls.
Right?
Just slab and columns.
Then the walls are
all in-filled.
Unfortunately, the walls
became permanent,
as all walls do.
So even that would've been--
the idea of a building with
no walls was just
unbelievably modern.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
about the "V's in
"Massachusetts" on
the building.
Why "V's" and not "U's?
MARK JARZOMBEK: That's because
the Romans didn't have "U's"--
right?
So they were copying the Roman
script, and so Romans didn't
have "U", so everything
was "V".
So they didn't have--
it stuck.
AUDIENCE: Do you know anything
about the design or the
rationale behind the huge tunnel
system that we have
between all the buildings.
It seems to be a unique
feature of the campus.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah.
That, I don't know.
Maybe you guys might have
a little bit more
of a clue on that.
I think it would have came out
just almost accidentally, is
what I understand, but--
DAVID MINDELL: I think so, and
then I think that more
recently it's been explicit that
there's been connections
between the new buildings.
But that's a good paper
topic for somewhere.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Yeah,
that is a good topic.
AUDIENCE: There really aren't
that many more basement
systems rather than just the
regular systems, anyways.
I mean, there's a couple extra
hallways in the basement.
But in general, the buildings
are connected above ground
just as much as they
are underneath.
AUDIENCE: I'm thinking that
especially the connection
between Philips 66 and all the
way across the Kendall Square,
it seemed to be pretty
deliberate to want to do that.
In any case, I heard it was like
the second longest tunnel
system compared to
the Pentagon or
something like that.
I might have been [INAUDIBLE].
But it's pretty big.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Interesting.
MARK JARZOMBEK: The whole
building is designed on field
because, as you know from your
reading, this was all swamp.
And field is not a good place
to design a building on--
right?
Because it basically wants
to be a swamp again.
So the engineering of the
building-- basically you have
design of gigantic, basically,
bathtub slab--
right?
And the building sort of sits
in this huge footprint--
right?
Sort of sits down and you're--
and so in other words, you
just put a point in and a point
in it'll start leaning
and tilting-- right?
So you put a big platform,
and then you can put
your building on it.
So the engineering of this,
actually was hugely
complicated.
Done by a guy called Stone--
engineering firm Stone, which
was one of the largest
engineering firms in the
world at the time.
He was also a [? graduate. ?]
Freeman was so upset when they
hired Bosworth to take his
plan and basically botch it,
that he took his entire
research and burned it.
And so all that we have left
in the archives are these
really bad photographs, some
snapshot that someone took of
some of these sheets
that are left.
And they haven't given a cent
to MIT, ever-- right?
I mean, still today, if you
talk to the Freeman
[INAUDIBLE] guys, they go, we're
not coming, we're not
coming, we hate you guys.
Because he felt that he had
really studied this thing
exhaustively, and was going to
give MIT the best building
that they could possibly
imagine, and was upset that
MIT then basically went
for Bosworth.
And it's a conflict, as I
write about in my book,
between two different types
of identities--
right?
I mean, Freeman was a type of
modern person where he wanted
concrete, he wanted engineering,
he wants building
to be proud of itself as a civil
engineering expression.
And he understood that this
was the moment of history
where an institution
could do that.
And so he's sort of right.
But there was another type
of modern movement being
developed, which was the
modern corporation.
And MIT was sort of like trying
to figure out which one
do we want-- right?
And ultimately, they opted for
going with the idea that the
modern corporation is what an
institution like this is, as
opposed to a public
institution-- right?
So it was shifting from a public
institution, which had
to be humble and small to
a private institution--
right-- like it is
now-- right?
With one fell swoop when
Eastman gave the
$10 million, right?
Boom, it's a private
institution.
So private institutions operate
on very different
representational models.
So being in the world--
having an argument about
your position in the
world was key to that.
And for that--
only architects at the time
knew how to do that--
right?
I don't know if they still know
how to do it, but that
was the point.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Was there
a time prior to the
Freeman-Bosworth divide that
architects and engineers
considered themselves
one in the same?
Or did that never exist?
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yes, probably
in the 1880s, I think
architecture and engineering
were a lot closer.
Then, engineering
professionalized itself much
earlier than architecture.
Engineering was already
professionalized practically
in the 1880s, whereas
architecture started to
professionalize itself
around 1900.
And even then, many architects
were going, we don't want to
be professional,
we are artists.
So really, it was only in
the 1940s, really, that
architecture as a professional
practice really takes root,
really with the second
World War.
So being a professional practice
gave engineers a
powerful leg to stand on.
Because they understood
deliverables, they understood
how buildings operate and
function in the real world,
whereas architects could give
you the appearance--
right-- but not know anything
about how to build it.
And that split begins to emerge
around 1900, between
architecture as a design
project, and engineering.
So in other words, when civil
engineering and architecture
start two different
fields-- right--
that's when they have
this antagonism.
But because engineers were so
incredibly competent, they
could build buildings
in their sleep.
I mean, sort of dumb
buildings-- right?
So they thought, that's how
you should be building.
So the engineers had something
to argue for themselves.
They make buildings, they knew
how to make them safe, they
don't burn, they don't do this,
so that's all you need
to do-- right?
So that antagonism basically
heats up around 1900, and this
is an example of that.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Where does
William Ware stand in this?
Was he an engineer
slash architect?
Or was he--
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah, he was
sort of the gentlemen
architect tradition idea.
So he's the one who founds the
Department of Architecture
along the gentleman model--
right?
And, yes, the engineering is
important, but engineering
still was something that wasn't
too much of a problem
because if you make these types
of buildings, you make
your walls, you put
in some big beams.
There's not a big question--
right?
But if you make MIT out of
concrete, in a million square
feet-- and how do you pour it?
How do you--
on the swampy soil?
This is an engineering problem
of mega proportions--
right?
And this is not for
an architect .
So architecture in the mid-20th
century was at a
scale that engineering wasn't
a real problem, because most
of it was just pretty
easy to do.
But as soon as you make big
buildings like this--
MERRIT ROE SMITH:
Different story.
MARK JARZOMBEK: --engineer has
to be really front and center.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Interesting.
AUDIENCE: Isn't the divide
between architecture and
engineering still a big
problem at MIT?
Because you look at buildings
like the Stata Center, in a
sense they both have--
they're both very artistic,
but have a lot
of structural problems.
So isn't that still a pretty
modern problem?
MARK JARZOMBEK: Well my uncle,
who is an architect lawyer,
architects come to him to get
them out of lawsuits.
So he always says, there's no
such thing as a building that
doesn't leak--
rule one-- and there's no such
thing as a good building that
doesn't have a lawsuit.
And so someone's always suing
something because--
no one knows.
I mean, my windows in
my Building 10,
they leak, I mean.
And they're rusted shut--
the upper one--
I just like-- you can't
even move it.
Just-- you know.
So that's maybe a question of
maintenance, rather than design.
But I'm a little bit more
sympathetic to Gary.
I think some of the lawsuit
anxiety is misplaced a bit.
Because most buildings of that
scale are going to have
mistakes and problems.
And anyway, almost every
Gary project gets sued.
You get sued.
For every building, he's
got a lawsuit.
So when MIT hired him, they
should have known that.
It's sort of like, don't they
read the newspapers?
So it's just a little bit
his fault, a little bit
everybody's fault.
The client should
of known better.
If they're going to get a
building that is designed at
the cutting edge of a certain
type of technological
revolution, there might be
problems, and so forth.
If they wanted a simpler
building, they shouldn't have
done it with Gary.
That's the point.
DAVID MINDELL: So in the
Bosworth-Freeman story, would
you describe the main group that
we ended up with as kind
of a solution that reflects
some anxiety on the
institute's part?
Because they voted for--
and as the corporations had some
anxiety, too, trying to
communicate their permanence and
their established nature,
which clearly indicates it's in
question, as we read with
all the mergers, and all
this sort of stuff?
As opposed to whether Freeman,
or somebody else, pushing
forward light spaces,
international style, very new,
very cutting edge, but leaving
open the question of whether
it was really the establishment
or not.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah, one of the
points about the book is
that MIT had to learn how to
find it's patronage voice--
right?
So when they first say, we want
a building, the guy just
walked down to the store
somewhere to Central Square
and saw someone that said
"architect" and said , oh, can
you design this for us?
Right?
They didn't imagine this to be
anything more complicated than
just going out and getting
box of cereal.
Then they had to learn that this
was a historical moment.
So they really didn't see
that at the beginning.
They just thought, we just want
a campus and get some
buildings up.
And what Freeman forced him
to do was to slow down and
understand the historical
moment.
Once they understood historical
moment, in a way
thanks to Freeman--
right--
they put everything aside and
waited a year or two for him
to make his research.
They actually thought more about
the historical moment
than Freeman wanted them to.
Because they said, the moment
isn't just to do a great
factory-style campus.
The really historical moment
is our new relationship and
identity as a private
institution, dependent on the
corporate institution.
And so that's the actual
thing we need--
right?
So they had to learn how to find
that, thanks to Freeman.
But actually, thanks
to Freeman, then
they went past Freeman--
right--
and articulated a different
project.
It was a huge spectacle.
It was a age where a vast public
spectacle-- this one,
the early 20th century--
where something happened that
you could do these things.
So yeah, there was a searchlight
on top of the
Rogers building, and there's
a searchlight on top of MIT
building-- the Dome.
And they got these from some
Navy frigate that was out in
the dock harbor-- they borrowed
the searchlights.
And then everybody left the
procession down from the
Rogers building to the dock.
And then there was a special
boat, and they all
piled on to the boat.
And the boat almost sank
because no one had ever
bothered to figure out what
800 people weigh.
And that would have
been interesting--
right?
It would have been a very
different story today about
the death of the faculty--
MERRIT ROE SMITH: The charter
sinks into the Charles.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Students dying
and swimming and--
DAVID MINDELL: I've heard that
that building's actually in
the Charles.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Yeah, that's
what I've heard, too.
DAVID MINDELL: Does anybody know
where you walk by that
boat everyday?
Where you see it everyday?
There's a huge picture of it
right at the end of the
Infinite Corridor, right
here on this wall.
I just walked by it
this morning.
And it was also the last one in
this whole little collage
about that set of events.
MARK JARZOMBEK: And then they
got on the boat and they went
off to the dock.
MIT was supposed to have
a dock, which was
never actually built.
And then they all got out.
And then every student was
participating, in one way or
other, in an opera that was
custom designed called--
what was the name of this?
I can't remember--
The Grey World, or something
like that, which featured the
history of the world
with MIT at the
culminating piece of that.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Of course.
MARK JARZOMBEK: And it featured
this woman called
Tanner, who was this great
swirly, dirly--
not wearing many clothes and
illuminated with red and
purple and orange lights
down below.
It was one of the great first
light show events--
right?
They would take with lights
going off and on [INAUDIBLE].
But this was one of the
first experiments in
colored light shows.
And Tanner did her
swirly dance.
And then the big opera came.
And the music came.
And Rockefeller gave a speech.
And everybody gave speeches.
And da, da, da, da.
And Cram, who was the head of
the department, was the master
of ceremonies.
And then he opened the door.
And then the two searchlights
were touching, like this.
And then when you open
the door, the
searchlights went like that.
And the MIT-Roger Williams
searchlight cut off, and you
only had MIT searchlight on.
And so that was the great,
heroic moment.
I mean, you could imagine
it was spectacular.
But it was all at night, so
there's only one photograph
that someone drew in to show a
little bit what it was like.
But you couldn't photograph
any of that stuff.
MARK JARZOMBEK: The Rogers
building was used until--
it was only torn down the '20s,
or even later-- right?
In the 30--
DAVID MINDELL: The main group
was built in one big swoop
that was that time.
But then there were various
other pieces filled in until
the end of the '20s-- right?
It wasn't really complete
until around 1930--
MARK JARZOMBEK: That's right.
DAVID MINDELL: --when the last
of all what we now know as
[INAUDIBLE].
So if you look at them, they
look a little different
[INAUDIBLE].
MARK JARZOMBEK: That's
right, yeah.
That's right.
I mean, I. M. Pei, who
studied here--
DAVID MINDELL: [INAUDIBLE]
stayed over [INAUDIBLE].
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah, see
architecture is over there, so
I. M. Pei, who studied here when
he was here in the '40s--
he was in the Rogers
building, still.
He was like the last student
to use that building .
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
MIT building for--
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah, it was
still-- they rented it, the
various floors at that time.
Then, sadly, it was torn down.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: That's
interesting.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Well, there's
sort of a playfulness about
it, which I think
one has love.
MIT had this incredible--
you read, also, the skits that
were being performed.
MIT had this tradition of
skits and theater skits.
And in the yearbook you see
these guys will be dressed up
as god knows what.
And they make some skit
imitating some professors or
doing [INAUDIBLE].
We lost all that.
I mean, somewhere MIT became
very serious, and all that
playful skits and irony
just went somewhere.
I don't know where.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: It went
to the students.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Isn't
that what you were
saying in your paper?
AUDIENCE: I feel like it's still
around, maybe on the
undergraduate level.
But I feel like MIT is a more
unique place than the other
college campus, just because
of some of the
weird stuff we do here.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Yeah,
good point.
DAVID MINDELL: But I think
your point is right.
The spectacle of that
[INAUDIBLE]
was a moment in time when--
who knows what?
There was enough technology
to bring a lot of people
together, but people weren't
yet jaded by radio and
television.
Where they wouldn't put all of
their effort in to that thing.
The allegories and all of the
performances was something we
studied a lot with the 150th.
And try to figure out what parts
of it are repeatable and
what parts--
MARK JARZOMBEK: --are goofy.
DAVID MINDELL: --are not.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: So I take
it, that's not going to be
repeated this spring.
DAVID MINDELL: Well, Professor
Smith is going to dress up as
Merlin for [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Well, if you
do-- if you dare do something
like that, David,
I'll be Merlin.
I don't think you dare do it.
DAVID MINDELL: [INAUDIBLE]
MIT charter in it.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Oh yeah.
DAVID MINDELL: Across the river,
almost like Raiders of
the Lost Ark.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: Wasn't the--
it was like a Venetian
galley, wasn't it?
That was built to carry the
stuff across the river?
MARK JARZOMBEK: That's right,
the Venetian was a theme.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: And it was
built up in Gloucester or
somewhere, and they had to bring
it down along the coast.
MARK JARZOMBEK:That's right.
MERRIT ROE SMITH: And I think
it's in your book, that you
talk about how it got damaged
on the way, or something.
And they were worried
about it sinking.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Well, they were
worried about it sinking
because they'd never really
thought about people in it.
And they'd never tested it.
I mean, it's just a barge,
dressed up with all
that stuff on it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When we go to the MIT
Museum, Debbie Douglas has
a piece of that, a piece
of the plaster.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Oh, really?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Really?
Oh, interesting.
AUDIENCE: And she tells
me that it's still out
there on the river.
And maybe we'll drag sonar
around and see
if we can find it.
AUDIENCE: Well, get that
side-scan sonar.
He's an expert on this stuff.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah,
let's go find it.
Yeah, it was a great
moment for MIT.
There's no doubt.
[? Elliot ?] was at
the ceremony.
AUDIENCE: Was he really?
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah.
But, I mean, you could--
they were just clearly
probably chafing
at the bit on this.
It was a huge [INAUDIBLE].
And it was a great
moment for MIT.
The reality was they were
practically bankrupt again.
Because they had this
great building.
But the building was vastly
over-expensive, by more
expensive than the
10 millions.
And so Eastman kept on
dishing out millions
and millions millions.
And you got to remember, 10
million back then, I mean,
it's not 10 million even
[INAUDIBLE] today.
But you probably have
to add a zero.
So it's something like 100
million, which is a huge
amount as a single gift to
create a building like this.
I mean, it's like an
unbelievable event in the
history of philanthropy.
American philanthropy is just
one of these great, marvelous
inventions.
I mean, one can think
about capitalism in
all sorts of ways.
But you go around the world
and capitalism does not
produce philanthropy like it
ever did in the America sense.
And this is one of the great
moments of that.
AUDIENCE: That's interesting.
AUDIENCE: It said that he's
been donating money as
[INAUDIBLE].
MARK JARZOMBEK: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: He was known
as Mr. Smith.
And he didn't want
to be known.
So when did he--
MARK JARZOMBEK: When
did he come out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, when did he
tell everybody that he was
[INAUDIBLE].
MARK JARZOMBEK: It came out, I
think, when Maclaurin died.
I think he leaked it out.
I mean, the whole thing
killed Maclaurin.
I mean, it made him
age overnight.
And within a few years,
he was dead.
I mean it's just astonishing,
they type of effort it takes,
the human and human cost,
to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It's in the Prescott
book, but not on the part that
was assigned, I think, where
they revealed the identity of
Eastman, with Eastman's
permission, once the whole
thing was done at a
reception for the
corporation at Gray House.
And Maclaurin basically went
upstairs and keeled over and
died at the reception at
the president's house.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Up in their
apartment's where [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] killed
a lot of presidents.
AUDIENCE: Somebody had a
question in their reflection
about why did Eastman give
the money to MIT.
He was not an MIT graduate.
Who asked that question?
Somebody did.
No?
Am I think--
boy, I'm having a
bad day here.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: --was why he
gave it anonymously.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Why?
Does anyone know?
MARK JARZOMBEK: I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Because I think in
Prescott's book, when MIT was
Boston Tech, isn't he the one
that says the reason why
Eastman gave the money was that
it had to do with the
fact that he employed a lot
of MIT graduates and was
impressed by them.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah.
But why he remained anonymous,
I have no idea.
AUDIENCE: Eastman was
a strange guy too.
AUDIENCE: Was he?
AUDIENCE: He was dead by suicide
within a few years
after all this happened
anyway, I've heard.
I've never seen any
evidence for this.
It's also interesting to look at
was that one of the sources
of MIT's big impact in 20th
century industry was that they
were so broke after they built
the buildings that they
basically laid off the faculty
one day a week and encouraged
them to make up their incomes
by consulting.
And it's still true today that
the faculty are allowed to
consult one day a week.
And that, born as a
budget-cutting measure,
actually ended up doing a lot
to diffuse MIT's technology
into [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Wow.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: But I've only
heard that as a story.
I've never actually seen any
documents about that.
AUDIENCE: Well, I know that in
the School of Engineering, not
in the School of Humanities
and Social Sciences, as
recently as 1980, assistant
professors were required to
raise I think it was
50% of their salary
through outside grants.
And associate professors had to
raise a certain percentage.
And even full professors,
although it was a small
percentage at that point.
And that ended basically when
they started to go--
well, convert over
to a more endowed
professorships, things like that.
It was during a fund-raising
venture in the 1990s perhaps.
So that's lasted.
AUDIENCE: Do you think MIT's
relationship to it's
architecture has stayed
the same?
Or how has it changed
since 1960?
A lot has been said in
the last ten years.
MARK JARZOMBEK: As you point
out, MIT, so much went into
the main building that basically
the rest of the
campus, apart from the
president's house, the
dormitory [INAUDIBLE]
just didn't really get built.
So that, I mean, for better or
for worse, I don't know.
But the dormitory section was
going to be behind Walker,
that whole area.
And eventually they built those
two dorms back there.
But they're absolutely
nothing like what
Bosworth had really planned.
He planned a whole little sort
of community back there.
So that opened up sort
of this territorial
problem about expansion.
So the idea of a mega building
expanding but always be one
building then also went against
the modernist ethos of
free-standing great buildings
and so forth.
So you had the library
building,
which is a lovely building.
It's '51 or something
like that.
But that was supposed
to be the library.
Then where the music hall was
is a little student center.
AUDIENCE: Which building
is this?
MARK JARZOMBEK: The
Hayden Library.
That's right.
So there's a courtyard.
And the courtyard belonged to
the little student center.
So where the music library is
would be the student center.
The doors would open up.
And at night you could have
social life and then
professors.
So it was professors,
books, and students.
It was a whole little island.
Well, that lasted for all
of five or six years.
And then the library
wanted more space.
And the professors wanted
more space.
And to hell with the
student life.
So they got rid of those.
So the courtyard died.
And now no one goes into
the courtyard.
And it's sort of sad.
You know, they put some
statues in there.
But that was [INAUDIBLE]
experiment.
But it was exactly an
anti-Bosworth world.
Let's build a building like a
little enclave as opposed to
this sort of connected tissue.
So that was the beginning of
sort of the mistakes, I think,
that the campus eventually
made.
Then they built these buildings
which sort of
continue it but don't
really continue.
Whereas these buildings were
designed, obviously, in
continuation of the courtyard
to some degree.
And I do like these
buildings better.
But basically this part of the
campus just got fizzled up and
chewed up with discontinuous
buildings.
The worst building of them all
is building nine on Mass Ave,
designed by Skidmore,
Owings, and Merrill.
So you know which one.
You have the steps going
up to your left.
It's sort of a modern thing.
AUDIENCE: It's also,
like, connected--
MARK JARZOMBEK: And it
completely disconnected.
AUDIENCE: No--
MARK JARZOMBEK: It's connected,
but not on the
third floor.
And the fourth floor, you've
got to go down some steps.
Because they wanted to put five
floors in the space of
three floors.
AUDIENCE: It didn't used
to be that way.
That happened with
the library.
It used to be connected.
MARK JARZOMBEK: That's right.
So the idea of these giant
floors and ceilings was a big
problem for these modern
buildings because by this time
we had ventilation.
And we don't need to have
12-foot, 20-foot floors.
You want 8-foot, 9-foot, and
then you're done with it.
So you can pack much more floor
space that you could in
these older buildings.
But it means, of course, that
you're going to ruin any kind
of continuity of that.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
MARK JARZOMBEK: And then they
refurbished these buildings.
They weren't too bad.
The skins of these buildings
used to be orange and yellow,
which I thought was
really lovely.
And then they painted it this
sort of blah, MIT blah--
[LAUGHTER]
MARK JARZOMBEK: I don't
know, white.
Not white, it's sort
of beige, beige-y.
They painted everything, just
sort of toned everything down
when they did the big
restoration of these
buildings, which I think
is really sad.
But yeah, I mean, it
was a problem.
I mean, campus design in the
beginning of the '40s through
the war, after the war, into
'70s, was basically big,
chunky buildings.
And this went against-- and it
was great for everywhere else.
It was great for
other campuses,
which had big spaces.
You could put a big
chunky building.
So we got our student center,
which is the big, ugly chunky
building designed by the
former dean of MIT.
So that's how you design
buildings.
And this idea of these sort of
continual flow buildings,
open-ended spaces just wasn't
going to happen.
And the Gehry building
tries to return a
little bit to that.
I mean, that's the great
thing about it.
It tries to actually re-envision
a world where you
can go into space and there's
some flexibility of ownership
to some degree.
AUDIENCE: The student center
and the Dewey Library,
Political Science Building
remind me of--
I don't know if they were
designed by the same person.
But were they built during
the Vietnam War period?
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah.
Well, '68.
AUDIENCE: They remind me
of being-- they're
like frontier garrisons.
They're like stockades, and
walled-off, and very
defensible looking.
MARK JARZOMBEK: You
can date these
buildings 1968 to '72 usually.
The University's basically
decided students are bad.
We're going to make buildings
that look like fortresses--
they're made out of concrete--
that they can't ruin, destroy,
beat up, or do anything with.
The student center
has a certain
elegance to it's design.
And look at it at night, it's
actually quite spectacular.
But basically it is a fortress,
I mean, literally.
It's got the shooting
arrows up there.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK JARZOMBEK: I mean,
[MAKES SHOOTING NOISES].
Like, what kind of a message
does that send?
I mean, that is like not good.
But every university
in America has one.
This is very popular among-- you
know, the administrators
want mean-looking buildings.
AUDIENCE: Why do the interesting
buildings like
Kresge, which is kind of not
normal, and the chapel, and
the Stata Center [INAUDIBLE].
MARK JARZOMBEK: In the '50s.
And after the '50s, MIT
had this process--
you might know more about it--
the new man type thing.
Which they were afraid that MIT
students were going to be
too engineering oriented.
And they wanted MIT students
to have culture, so be
cultural representatives.
So the idea of the Kresge
Auditorium was where
symphonies could be held.
And people could
learn something
about symphonies, music.
And the nondenominational chapel
was a place where we
sort of think.
You know, after the war, and
after the atom bomb, MIT felt
a little guilty about
all that stuff.
So this was where we're
going to try to heal.
And so we need scientists who
are healing agents and who are
sophisticated people, not just
going to go out and make bombs
and whatever.
So this was part
of that thing.
Yeah, so that was a very
sliver of a moment.
And that's when the [INAUDIBLE]
gets formed.
So it's part of the emergence
of humanities departments.
AUDIENCE: I loved what you said
in your lecture when you
were describing the emergence
of different
schools, 1873, 1900.
You said--
I don't know if you purposely
said it, but you said it.
And you said here we see
modernity being formed.
I thought that is a very
interesting comment.
To see these departments
changing and shifting, that's
a very interesting comment.
AUDIENCE: Another good student
project would be to make a
family tree of the MIT
department's over time.
People have done these trees
with other kinds
of knowledge systems.
And sort of show how each
department either morphed or
got substituted over
time coming down.
Because we talked a lot about
or a little bit about that
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: This was actually
something I found online.
The San Diego Club of MIT
has a list of all of the
departments course numbers
corresponding
with things in history.
AUDIENCE: How do you find it?
Do you just Google it?
AUDIENCE: I can send
it to you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, great.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Yeah, the point
is to understand that
all these shifts reflect things
that are happening in
the outside world.
So in what way does this map,
which is what this is, give us
the topography of the world?
We don't see what's happening
in the outside world.
I can't remember when it was,
but in 1943 there's a
psychology department.
And it lasts about 10 years.
And then it disappears.
And you sort of scratch
your head.
You know, what was that about?
Well, a lot to do with
military psychology.
And things like that.
So all of the shifting
signifiers of these
departments are really sort of
traces of energies that are
taking place.
And MIT, in an odd way, is
really-- you know, something
could happen and you
can sort of see it.
I mean, it doesn't take 20 years
or 30 years for these
departments.
What's beautiful about [? MIT ?]
is the really rapid
elasticity of these departments
in coming and going.
So in the 1880s, when it was
the great evolution, if you
will, of the idea of a
professional class--
it happened very rapidly in the
1880s, the emergence of a
professional class, politically,
in so many ways--
you just sort of see
that in the MIT
departmental structure.
From a gentlemanly class to a
professional class, and it
just happens right there.
And all of these changes are
mapping these forces.
And it's a great way, it would
be certainly a great thesis to
use that as indicators.
AUDIENCE: It would
be, definitely.
AUDIENCE: When did people start
referring to the courses
by their number?
So, like, was it confusing for
a while when they were making
all these changes?
Or did no one say, like,
oh, [INAUDIBLE]
use that terminology?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Good question.
Debbie Douglas, when she comes,
we should ask her.
Because I know she has a
particular way of thinking
about that.
There are lots of suppositions,
I guess.
And I don't know that anyone
has the answer.
But she has some pretty
interesting things to say
about how the numbering
system came about.
AUDIENCE: Anybody hear of the
Engineering Systems Division?
It's a big thing on
campus today.
And I've been very involved
with them.
And 10 years ago when it was
just forming, we used to have
these off-campus retreats a
couple times a year to talk
about what this department or
division was going to be.
And it was sort of a lot
of hand-wringing.
But there were people in the
room from six or eight
different schools of engineering
and the management
school and humanities and all
kinds of different places, and
they were all talking
together.
And at the time, MIT had a big
relationship with Cambridge
University in the UK.
Still have a little
bit of that, the
Cambridge MIT Institute.
And there were a couple
of guests there
one year from Cambridge.
And we spent a whole day sort
of with this kind of
conversation, and a little
bit anxious about
what's it going to be?
How's it going to
define itself?
Where are all these people?
And at the end of the day, the
people from Cambridge raised
their hand and they said, I
just have to tell you, as
worried as you all are about how
you're going to make this
thing work, from where
we come from it looks
just totally amazing.
Because at Cambridge, a
department gets formed.
And then for 600 years nobody
talks to anybody else in any
of the other departments.
And you can't even get people
in the same room together to
talk about this issue.
And here there are people from
ten different departments
talking about this.
And that was just one of those
moments that sort of puts into
relief what's so fluid
about this place.
MARK JARZOMBEK: I mean,
civil engineering is
now subsumed, right?
What happened to civil
engineering?
It's one.
It's still one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think it is.
I was going to--
I wanted to say something
about I call it boundary
crossing that takes
place here at MIT.
It has surely picked up here
in the last 10 years.
I mean, you see it when
students that major in
mechanical engineering end up
doing what I would identify as
electrical engineering.
You know, there's just
lots of crossing
over in research groups.
And had that existed
since when?
Were there more--
there must have been stricter
disciplinary divides between
these departments as you
go back in time.
But I don't know exactly when
do you identify the end of
that and the beginning of more
of these interdisciplinary
collaborations?
Is it World War II,
[? NORAD ?] lab or
something like that?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I saw, like,
in the MIT Museum, that little
place where they
had like the--
something about, like,
electrical engineering and
[INAUDIBLE]
basically or Psychology.
So that was in the 1940s.
And they show up as one of the
first interdisciplinary
projects at MIT where they
combined electrical
engineering and, like,
proto-computers.
AUDIENCE: So it's World
War II-ish anyway.
AUDIENCE: I think it also
relates to, like you saw from
Mark's chart, if you're talking
about English, and
history, and law, and theology,
you really do have
these 600-year traditions.
But beginning with the sciences
and certainly in
engineering, there's no field
of engineering that's older
than 200 years.
And most of them are less
than 100 years old.
So any time you're in that
game-- and the same is true,
to some degree, of
the sciences--
and things are professionalizing
over the
course of--
the boundaries are not
particularly hard.
I mean, electrical engineering
is this funny combination of
physics and other kinds
of engineering that
comes out in the 1880s.
And computer science, that's
also a strange hybrid of
psychology, and mathematics,
and electrical engineering.
So at any given point, the
disciplines that we have in a
technical school are only ever
going to be 40 or 50 years old
in a certain way.
AUDIENCE: But it seems to have
really increased in the last
15 years or so around
here anyway.
There's a lot going on.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think when Roz
Williams comes in, she'll
talk about the sort of anxieties
about are the
engineering disciplines worth
anything at all anymore.
I actually think they are.
But that's another
conversation.
MARK JARZOMBEK: Well,
engineering strikes me, from
the architect, as going downhill
in the United States,
going uphill in Europe.
I don't know why there's
a bit difference.
But the crossover issue, I
think, at MIT is, I mean, when
I leave my office, I pass
a colleague's office.
I pass the skin lab.
I don't know what the hell
goes on in there.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK JARZOMBEK: That's where,
someone told me, they invented
artificial skin.
And then I pass a lab that built
a room with a lot of
nitrogen tanks sticking
out in the hall.
I don't know what the
hell is in there.
Then I pass a part
of a library.
Then I pass a student center.
I mean, if I go from my office
to the dean's office, down the
hall, I'm walking past three
or four departments who own
bits and pieces of
this landscape.
And it's very irritating.
Because to us, in the dean's
office, we're going God.
I mean why do we have to walk
all the way around.
But on the other hand,
it's very MIT.
This sort of odd, gerrymandering
of space that
we have, as frustrating as it
is, is actually interesting.
It's sort of unique.
You can go to Harvard to the
architecture school.
And there are only a whole
building filled with
architects.
I'm not going to see people
making skin lab or see big
hydrogen tanks sitting out in
the hallway with smoke coming
out of them.
And I think that this is part
of MIT culture and should be
maintained.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I agree.
It makes it interesting.
AUDIENCE: OK, on that note,
I think we can--
MARK JARZOMBEK: All
right, guys.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank
you very much.